bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur LCP nous
sommes en direct effectivement pour une
émission spéciale consacrée aux 49-3 le
gouvernement a en effet l'intention vous
l'avez dit à d'utiliser l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution sur ce
projet de loi de finance qui permettrait
donc d'adopter le texte sans vote les
oppositions ayant clairement dit qu'elle
ne voterai pas le texte en dépit de
l'adoption de certains amendements
Olivier Véran a laissé entendre que ce
serait vraisemblablement aujourd'hui les
débats sur le projet de loi de finance
doivent normalement reprendre dans
quelques instants nous sommes donc
ensemble ici et j'accueille sur ce
plateau mes invités bonjour à vous
Charles vous êtes député renaissance du
Bas-Rhin Kevin mauvieux bonjour vous
êtes député rassemblement national de
l'Eure et Antoine léoman bonjour Merci à
vous vous êtes députés la France
insoumise de l'Essonne dans un instant
c'est Fabien diphilippo le député elle
est républicains la Moselle qui nous
rejoindra et Elsa managava est avec nous
bonjour Elsa pour l'Assemblée nationale
nous avons un dispositif spécial et nous
sommes en duplex avec Stéphanie
Despierres qui se trouve salle des
quatre colonnes et nous vous retrouvons
Stéphanie puisque vous êtes salle des
quatre colonnes il y a déjà un peu
d'ambiance autour de vous oui il y a de
l'effervescence ici parce qu'il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de journalistes qui
attendent de savoir si le 49-3 sera
dégainé par le gouvernement dans les
minutes dans l'heure qui vient on vient
de voir arriver Gabriel Attal le
ministre des comptes publics qui revient
parce que normalement la discussion sur
le projet de loi de finance 2023 va
recommencer après le débat de cet
après-midi sur le prélèvement pour
l'Union européenne les débats devraient
donc reprendre dans quelques minutes
alors il y a deux options soit ils
reprennent leur cours classiquement soit
la première ministre arrive monte à la
tribune et dit qu'elle a décidé
d'engager sa responsabilité donc le 49-3
merci Stéphanie Despierres on vous
retrouve bien évidemment tout au long de
cette émission alors si le 49-3 devait
être utilisé ce serait la première fois
sur un budget depuis Pierre Bérégovoy en
1992 pour le projet de loi de financeur
de 1993 mais c'est Michel Rocard qui
détient et bien le record de
l'utilisation avec 28 49.3 la dernière
fois qu'il a été utilisé c'était sous
François Hollande pour les lois Macron
et El khomri en 2015 et 2016 Elsa m'ont
un Gava on attend donc soit la reprise
des débats comme nous le disait
Stéphanie Despierres soit l'arrivée de
la première ministre tous les regards se
tournent donc vers Elisabeth borne oui
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est qu'à
15h en fait c'est pas le budget qui a
repris dans l'hémicycle c'était un débat
un peu index sur les recettes de l'Union
européenne pendant ce temps-là on sait
qu'Elisabeth borne la première ministre
elle était au Sénat pour répondre à la à
la séance de questions au gouvernement
et effectivement là à la dernière
oratrice elle est en train de parler sur
le texte et ensuite on s'attend en toute
vrais voulant savoir la première
ministre arriver je peux vous dire qu'on
a déjà vu un conseiller de la première
minis qui est là donc les ministres qui
reviennent moi j'ai croisé beaucoup de
députés de la majorité qui a-t-elle pas
pour rejoindre l'hémicycle comme
Stéphanie vous le disait c'est assez
rapide après elle monte à la tribune
elle dit qu'elle engage la
responsabilité du Gouvernement sur le
texte elle va évidemment donner des
éléments de contexte elle va très
certainement dire que c'est de votre
faute les oppositions parce que vous
avez dit dès le début que vous ne le
voterez pas et voilà elle va se
justifier un petit peu on peut penser un
discours d'une dizaine quinzaine de
minutes il y a pas de réponse des
oppositions ça suspend les débats on
aura en revanche évidemment beaucoup de
réactions salle des quatre colonnes là
où tous les journalistes attendent
impatiemment ce 49 des réactions qu'on
fera vivre bien évidemment en direct sur
LCP alors on sait que le Conseil des
ministres doit autoriser une éventuelle
autorisation du 49-3 utilisation du 49-3
ça déjà été fait la semaine dernière
donc ça peut intervenir d'un moment à
l'autre mais alors Elsa manager pourquoi
aujourd'hui finalement alors c'est vrai
vous nous le direz vous nous le
confirmerez peut-être on a pensé dans un
premier temps que ce 49-3 il allait
arriver beaucoup plus tôt comme tout le
monde savait qu'il allait arriver
pourquoi discuter plus longtemps que
prévu et finalement le gouvernement a
décidé bien de laisser le débat vivre
dans l'hémicycle pour plusieurs raisons
alors vous n'êtes pas forcément d'accord
monsieur le moins vous nous direz
pourquoi déjà parce que et bien les
débats ils se sont plutôt bien tenus
donc le gouvernement n'a pas forcément
eu d'opportunité de dire regarder il y a
du blocage il y a de l'obstruction il y
a eu aussi et bien un contexte social
qui a percuté un peu cet examen du
budget votre marche notamment des
parties de la gauche dimanche la grève
mardi est-ce qu'il était judicieux de
mettre un 49-3 en plein milieu pas
forcément et puis bien du coup on a
décidé d'aller presque jusqu'au bout
normalement le texte budgétaire il est
inscrit à l'heure du jour de l'Assemblée
nationale jusqu'à ce soir minuit le
gouvernement va dire bah voilà en fait
le temps est un parti un peu épuisé
alors on n'est pas du tout au bout du
texte puisque là on en est à après
l'article 4 donc en fait on soit si on a
voulu aller jusqu'au bout du bout du
bout du bout il aurait fallu encore des
jours et des jours et des jours d'examen
voilà beaucoup beaucoup d'heures il y a
57 heures de débats qui ont eu lieu
actuellement sur ce projet de loi de
finance il y a eu du débat dans
l'hémicycle on va y revenir bien sûr
avec nos invités Charles
dites-nous vous quels sont les dernières
informations dont vous disposez est-ce
que vous vous apprêtez à revenir dans
l'émission pour poursuivre le débat sur
le budget ou est-ce que vous attendez
plutôt à voir Elisabeth borne je suis
pas dans les dans les petits secrets je
suis pas Elizabeth borne donc je ne sais
pas après le porte-paro du gouvernement
je crois était assez clair il est fort
probable que que cet article sera
utilisé aujourd'hui et la vraie question
c'est pourquoi est-ce que le
gouvernement doit utiliser cet article
on a eu des élections législatives au
mois de juin les Français nous ont donné
un message très clair c'est aucun groupe
ne dispose de la majorité absolue tout
le monde est minoritaire il y a certes
une majorité relative autour des trois
groupes de la majorité et pour faire
voter les textes vous devez travailler
ensemble en tout cas qui est
plus de groupes que les trois groupes de
la majorité pour faire passer les textes
ce qui s'est passé sur ce budget c'est
que avant que l'on commence l'examen du
texte tous les groupes de position pas
simplement les groupes qui sont
radicalement opposés à Emmanuel Macron
et les filles et la rations le National
mais même les groupes d'opposition avec
lesquels on avait pu travailler cet été
faire voter le paquet pouvoir d'achat
tous les groupes d'oppositions dit ont
de votre APPLE budget donc à partir de
ce moment il faut qu'il y a un budget
pour la France et la Constitution offre
cette possibilité d'utiliser l'article
on va y revenir mais est-ce que vous
Kevin mot vieux par exemple vous vous
attendez à ce qu'il y ait à 49-3
aujourd'hui là la reprise des débats ou
pas évidemment et comme le disait votre
collègue on l'anticipait enfin on avait
prévu effectivement nous que ça arrive
en tout cas moi à titre personnel je
pensais que ça arriverait plutôt je
m'attendais à vendredi la semaine
dernière pour tout vous dire parce que
derrière le 49-3 il y a aussi une
stratégie de communication du
gouvernement on va pas faire semblant la
gouvernement ça a été de dire on laisse
le Parlement débattre on fait comme si
tout se passait bien on fait comme si on
écoutait les oppositions on fait comme
on voulait être constructif alors qu'en
réalité il en est absolument rien et
étant donné que c'est une stratégie de
communication j'ai cru effectivement
qu'en fin de semaine dernière ça
sortirait pour essayer de cacher un
petit peu la grande sociale au niveau
des carburants au niveau des
manifestations du week-end au niveau de
la grève d'hier et en fin de compte il
en a été rien ça je pense que ça va
effectivement tomber aujourd'hui on l'a
un peu évoqué hier dans l'hémicycle ce
qui me fait dire que ça va tomber
aujourd'hui alors au-delà du fait qu'il
y a des personnalités qui sont déjà vues
dans le palais et qui sont qui donnent
des indices il y a le côté où hier soir
la question était posée par plusieurs
députés pas de notre groupe mais par
plusieurs députés notamment de la France
insoumise de savoir si le calendrier
d'examen du projet de loi de finance
allait être prolongée si on allait
ouvrir des plages parce qu'effectivement
il reste encore des centaines et des
centaines d'amendements
les discussions sont censées s'arrêter
ce soir à minuit pour poursuivre demain
sur un autre texte qui sera le projet de
financement de la sécurité sociale il
reste des centaines d'amendements et
aucun a été ouvert donc on se doute que
s'il y a pas nécessité d'ouvrir d'autres
créneaux c'est que le débat s'arrête
aujourd'hui ça semble logique après
j'ai envie de dire si le 49-3 tombe
c'est effectivement parce qu'il y a
aucune majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
qui Emmanuel Macron bien qu'il ait été
élu n'a pas la majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale et je pense que les Français
là dessus sont très déçus d'une chose et
qu'ils ont envoyé une assemblée
représentative de de leur pensée de leur
volonté du courant qu'on peut trouver
dans le pays il s'attendait à ce qui est
du débat constructif à ce qui est des
avancées et les Français ont constaté
que pendant toute l'étude qu'on a pu
faire de cette première partie de projet
de loi de finance aucun amendement n'a
été accepté par la majorité quasiment
aucun tout est refusé en bloc à chaque
fois avec des arguments parfois
totalement
on va y revenir sur sur ces arguments et
on va poursuivre le débat Antoine et au
moins juste vous vous y attendez
maintenant est-ce que ça vous paraît
imminent ou pas et est-ce que vous le
souhaitez bah je crois qu'il y a pas
beaucoup de doutes je veux dire quand on
voit la présence policière à l'extérieur
de de l'hémicycle avec des le camion de
CRS qui sont disposés je pense que le
gouvernement à la fois va imposer les
choses à l'Assemblée nationale et se
préparent à ce que des manifestations
spontanées qui pourraient avoir lieu
soit soit gérés vous avez dit quelque
chose de très juste en réalité si le
gouvernement n'a pas utilisé le 49-3
avant c'est parce qu'il était contraint
par la situation politique et sociale
nous avions dimanche dernier une marche
pour le pouvoir d'achat qui est
rassemblé un grand nombre de personnes
qui empêchaient d'utiliser le 49-3 avant
parce que ça se disait dans la macronie
ça aurait donné de l'eau à notre
mobilisation à notre moulin de la
mobilisation et puis ensuite vous aviez
une mobilisation sociale le mardi donc
même chose pas possible de l'utiliser le
lundi donc du coup le gouvernement s'est
retrouvé dans une situation où il a été
coincé en réalité il a été d'autant plus
coincé que ce débat qui a pu avoir lieu
a permis de mettre en avant un certain
nombre de propositions j'en retiens deux
qui me semblent les plus les plus
caractéristiques premièrement le
rétablissement de l'exit tax qui est un
mécanisme de lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale qui avait été supprimée par
Emmanuel Macron en 2018 et deuxièmement
la taxe sur les super dividendes
super dividende qui est donc été votée
par les oppositions on va y revenir mais
avant cela un point elles a mon un Gavin
encore une précision sur ce 49-3 qui
permet donc d'adopter un texte sans vote
mais quel texte en fait alors ça
normalement la première ministre va pas
forcément rentrer dans le détail mais
elle va dire et bien j'engage la
responsabilité du Gouvernement sur le
texte que vous trouverez annexer au
compte-rendu des débats ça va être connu
quasiment dans la foulée ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'il y a effectivement beaucoup
d'amendements qui ont été adoptés contre
la vie du gouvernement dont certains il
est sûr que le gouvernement ne veut
absolument pas les reprendre les deux
dont vous parliez sur les super profits
et sur l'exit tax le gouvernement a
quand même piocher dans quelques
amendements adopté de la veut même de la
majorité c'est pas forcément les plus
significatifs pour faire plaisir un
petit peu à tous les groupes pas au RN
ni à la France insoumise puisque le
gouvernement considère
et donc le gouvernement a pris quelques
centaines d'amendements votés contre son
avis mais encore une fois ce sont des
amendements qui restaient dans le cadre
du gouvernement c'est-à-dire pas d'être
supplémentaire pas d'impôts
supplémentaire donc c'est pas
franchement des amendements qui sont
très significatifs il y a quelque chose
qui merci on va vous retrouver un petit
peu plus tard dans cette émission oui
Antonio il y a quelque chose qui colle
pas en fait dans le discours du
gouvernement le 49-3 tel qu'il était
présenté par le gouvernement tel que
vous venez de le faire d'ailleurs c'est
présenté comme un outil de brutalisation
de l'opposition c'est à dire les
oppositions sont pas d'accord donc on va
utiliser le 49-3 comme ça le texte passe
et les oppositions n'ont rien à dire sur
le sujet or vu que certains amendements
ont été adoptés ils devient un mécanisme
de brutalisation de la propre majorité
d'Emmanuel Macron parce que l'amendement
sur les super dividendes ce n'est pas la
France insoumise ni le rassemblement
national qui l'a proposé c'est le modem
modem qui fait partie de la majorité
présidentielle et le MoDem a fait passer
cet amendement également avec le vote de
19 députés Renaissance dont le suppléant
de madame donc en utilisant ce ce 49-3
la majorité présidentielle va et enfin
le gouvernement va brutaliser sa propre
majorité ce qui est au final je me sens
pas au final peut-être que vous étiez
19 députés se sentent pas très bien mais
si vous n'avez pas voté l'amendement sur
les super dividendes c'est votre choix
mais d'autres de vos collègues y compris
dans votre groupe ont décidé de le voter
alors justement qui nous a rejoint sur
ce plateau député les républicains de la
Moselle vous aussi vous l'avez voté cet
amendement sur les super dividendes qui
a priori ne devrait pas rester dans le
texte final sur le projet de loi de
finances qu'elle essaie entendre en tout
cas Bruno Le Maire ça vous le regrettez
vous non je pense que vous savez dans la
situation qu'on connaît que connaît
notre pays avec un budget qui nous est
présenté qui est déficitaire qui va
encore battre des records d'endettement
il faut se montrer responsable et on va
demander dans les temps qui viennent des
efforts à nos concitoyens et alors il
faut que et bien par moment on soit
capable de prendre la mesure de tout ça
et cet amendement il était très encadré
il faut vraiment réaliser quand vous
parlez de super dividende ça veut dire
des et bien des dizaines de pour cent
d'augmentation des dividendes versées
non pas par rapport à la période du
covid qui était très dure mais sur la
moyenne des cinq dernières années donc
pour pouvoir faire ça il faut vraiment
avoir rencontré des conditions
exceptionnelles au cours de de cette
année et puis par ailleurs bien ça
s'applique à seuil de chiffre d'affaires
750 millions d'euros qui est très très
élevé donc ça devait rapporter 200
millions d'euros c'est un amendement
symbolique en tout cas vous savez il y a
rien de symbolique il y a rien de
symbolique pour nos entreprises j'en ai
bien conscience mais par rapport à ce
qui nous est présenté aujourd'hui ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que l'effet boule
de neige de la dette engagée depuis
François Hollande maintenant avec
Emmanuel Macron qui s'accroît de plus en
plus vite on va avoir une charge de la
dette à la fin de la période d'Emmanuel
Macron qui sera de 90 milliards d'euros
sans doute ça sera de très très loin le
plus gros budget de l'État une fois et
demi le budget de l'Éducation nationale
qu'est-ce qu'on va laisser à nos enfants
qu'est-ce qu'on veut laisser à nos
enfants autre chose que de la dette
alors nous on a fait des propositions
vous savez par ailleurs pour faire des
économies pour pouvoir rendre l'argent
en français pour améliorer les services
publics de proximité mais que ce soit
financé tout ça ça a été balayé d'un
revers demain et donc et bien à un
moment donné nous on prend nos
responsabilités
je voudrais vous entendre sur c'est
super dividendes sur le texte finalement
qui sera conservé il y a un certain
nombre d'amendements qui ont été votés
contre la vie du gouvernement pourquoi
en retenir certains et pas d'autres mais
parce que on a mis
une ligne rouge extrêmement extrêmement
claire qui est que on ne dépassera pas
les 5% de déficit et ce qui s'est passé
depuis plusieurs jours que nous avons ce
débat budgétaire c'est que nous sommes
déjà si on prend la somme de tous les
amendements votés par l'opposition alors
je veux entendre mon collègue des
républicains nous faire un cours sur les
finances publiques alors que l'immense
majorité des amendements qu'ils posent
ce sont des des aggravations de niches
fiscale qu'ils ont déposé un amendement
symbolique en disant on va faire 20
milliards d'économies sur
l'administration et les lois
tout ça n'est pas sérieux je ne mens pas
et puis et puis et puis et voilà sept à
8 milliards d'aggravation du du déficit
c'est pas sérieux c'est pas sérieux et
nous avons une trajectoire de retour
sous les 3 % à la fin du du quinquennat
et on tiendra et on tiendra cette
objectif et qui n'est pas tenu c'est pas
tenable cet objectif il est fixé sur des
variables macroéconomiques qui sont
erronés voilà c'est totalement
erroné on part du principe de 1% de
croissance l'année prochaine l'année
prochaine je vous le dis c'est
stagnation l'année prochaine c'est
inflation et récession c'est mais c'est
récession de vous dites ça le FMI dit
que pour le moment nous aurons 0,7 que
nous allons éclater dans les grandes
économies européennes nous serons la
seule économie qui l'année prochaine
sera encore en croissance l'Allemagne va
être en récession l'Italie sera en
récession pour le moment de projection
du FMI de la semaine dernière
depuis l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron en
2017 les prévisions ont quasiment
toujours été revues à la baisse à une
exception
à une exception le l'après crise
sanitaire qui correspond un peu comme je
l'avais dit une fois comme ils sont des
finances au bébé qui tombe dans l'eau
arrivait au bout il tape du pied donc il
remonte d'un coup mais après plus fort
que d'autres il faut comprendre que vous
vous auriez souhaité plus de dépenses
dans ce budget ce qu'ils ont fait c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait alors attention
attention attendez il faut plus de
dépenses mais des bonnes dépenses ça
veut aussi dire qu'il y a des dépenses
qui sont à arrêter et qui permettent de
faire des économies le budget en fait la
grosse problématique qu'on a vu dans
cette première partie de PLF c'est que
le la majorité relative a essayé de
mettre en avant au maximum tous les
amendements qui prévoyaient des dépenses
pour pouvoir dire le mercredi 18 ou 19
qu'on va faire 49-3 parce que les
oppositions veulent dépenser mais on a
passé en catiminé tout un tas de de
d'amendements qu'on soit pour ou contre
il y en a de votre côté on a eu d'une
autre il y en a une partout qui
proposait de faire des économies et cela
on les balais d'un revers de la main
pour pouvoir dire après ils veulent
dépenser mais par contre ils font rien
rentrer dans les caisses il faut arrêter
un peu avec tout ça nous tout à l'heure
on parlait du débat sur le sur le budget
de l'Europe enfin c'est hallucinant de
voir contre 2017 et aujourd'hui le
budget que la France accorde à l'Europe
les versements que la France fait à
l'Europe a augmenté de plus de 50% il y
a 8 milliards d'euros de plus que la
France donne aujourd'hui à l'Europe
entre il y a 5 ans et aujourd'hui alors
qu'on vient de ne pas nous dire que
donner un milliard pour donner une demi
part à des veufs à des veuves quand rien
demandé qu'on la savait le rhum c'est
nous dire la France c'est pas encore
je trouve qu'il y a beaucoup
d'hypocrisie sur le sujet parce que les
amendements qui ont été proposés sont
des amendements qui font gagner de
l'argent les amendements dont on parle
le rétablissement de l'exit taxe et
d'augmentation des installations des
impôts mais attendez pas sur n'importe
qui des impôts des plus riches mais vous
êtes obsédé par les riches nous sommes
c'est des paris riches mais d'ailleurs
vous vous êtes en train de faire la
démonstration de ce que j'ai dit
d'ailleurs dans nous nous voulons
baisser les impôts pour 90% des Français
pour tous ceux qui gagnent moins de 4000
euros par mois nous voulons les baisser
les impôts pour les autres en revanche
nous voulons les augmenter parce qu'il
faut qu'ils participent davantage à au
financement de l'État et
particulièrement dans une période dans
laquelle on nous dit que si on ne fait
rien il va falloir faire la retraite à
65 ans non c'est pas ça qu'il faut faire
il faut que ceux qui ont beaucoup
participent davantage et que la classe
moyenne cesse de de prendre sur son dos
l'essentiel de la charge mais voilà ce
qu'il faut faire et pourquoi le
gouvernement fait passer un 49-3 parce
qu'il n'est pas d'accord avec cette
police non c'est son choix mais non
parce que toutes les oppositions nous
avons parlé
nous avons parlé notamment nous avons
parlé notamment du rétabli il y a eu
d'ailleurs des clarifications politiques
notamment du côté du rassemblement
national nous avons proposé de rétablir
l'ISF l'ISF sur les valeurs mobilières
et sur les valeurs alors le débat il a
eu lieu dans l'hémicycle et ça a été
rejeté exactement il y a eu une
clarification politique qui était
intéressante je pense pour les Français
qui est que le rassemblement national a
voté contre le rétablissement de l'ISS
tels sur les classes moyennes non tel
qu'il est sûr que c'est bon allez les
les les maisons les maisons de plus de
400000 €, on parle pas des classes
moyennes
400000 €, moi je suis en Normandie si
vous allez sur la côte normande il y a
des pavillons aujourd'hui
400000 € dites-moi combien de fois vous
avez un pavillon c'est 400000 € et un
pavillon je savais combien vous savez
combien ça concerne de personnes donc
mais il s'agit il s'agit d'un d'un
impôts sur sur l'ensemble des valeurs
sur valeurs mobilières et immobilière
mais le sujet du rétablissement de
l'impôt sur les valeurs mobiles que nous
proposions nous c'était de faire en
sorte que nous actions davantage la
fortune en action celle de Bernard
Arnaud par exemple puisque les Ultra
riches ont une fortune qui est
essentiellement en action et sur ce
sujet là et bien nous n'avons pas pu
trouver une majorité je le regrette
c'est dommage
vous avez pu vous exprimer vous les
républicains vous avez pu faire passer
d'ailleurs un certain nombre
d'amendements qui pourraient même être
retenu dans le texte final est-ce que
vous avez une forme de frustration par
rapport à ce projet de loi de finances
c'est excessivement difficile quand vous
savez dès le départ que le gouvernement
va employer le 49-3 et bien de jouer le
jeu du débat on s'est battu sur chaque
amendement parce que c'est des combats
qu'on veut porter à long terme et
là-dessus tout le monde a joué le jeu et
moi ce que je regrette dans la situation
qui est celle de notre pays celle de nos
territoires de nos concitoyens c'est que
le gouvernement et vous l'avez décrit
avant mon entrée sur le plateau pour des
raisons de communication et de marketing
politique nous a baladé pendant
plusieurs jours en nous faisant attendre
le moment où il déclencherait ce 49-3
alors qu'on a pas deux jours à perdre
dans la situation du pays il faut
avancer sur ces sujets maintenant
permettez-moi juste de vous donner trois
chiffres pour que vous compreniez bien
l'hypocrisie qui peut être celle de la
de la majorité et des marcheurs ou des
macronistes et bien le premier quand on
vous dit oui 5% du déficit c'est pas 5%
du budget de l'État
ces 5% du PIB ça veut dire qu'il va
encore emprunter cette année 45% de leur
recette 158 milliards c'est proche du
jamais vu donc ça c'est très dangereux
ensuite quand monsieur zinson school
nous dit vous proposez des dépenses pour
cette 8 milliards en additionnant toutes
les propositions des oppositions bien
mais quand je chiffre nos économies on
est sur 35 milliards d'euros d'économie
dans 20 milliards sur les surstructures
technocratiques bureaucratiques les
agences paragouvernementales et on a
parlé l'Agence nationale du sport on a
parlé d'un certain nombre de médiateurs
on a parlé de doublons avec les
ministères on a documenté tout ça et
enfin dernier exemple quand on nous
parle il ne faut pas dépenser plus il
faut revaloriser le travail nous à
droite nous portons ça mais nous le
portons réellement par contre ce que va
faire dans le pls et dans les mois à
venir le gouvernement s'est lancé une
expérimentation sur le versement
automatique du RSA sans même que les
gens et à le demander et ça si on le
généralise l'année prochaine l'année
suivante c'est 3 milliards d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires sur les
personnes qui à l'endroit au RSA et qui
ne savent pas forcément ou qui ne le
demandent pas la plupart d'oser de faire
des économies sur les non recours social
c'est pas de donner toujours plus d'aide
aux gens à un moment donné c'est de les
aider à trouver un travail et qu'il
puisse vivre dignement de leur travail
faire un petit des tours par la salle
des quatre colonnes sachez qu'en ce
moment en tout cas se déroule toujours
le débat sur les recettes au profit de
l'Union européenne des bas qui a lieu
dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale et juste après ce débat là et
son C reprendre celui sur le projet de
loi de finances voilà il pourrait il
veut évidemment commencer par une
intervention de la première ministre
pour annoncer le 49-3 mais pour l'heure
et bien toujours pas de Première
ministre Stéphanie Despierres vous êtes
seul des quatre colonnes on a vu
beaucoup de personnes arrivées derrière
vous beaucoup de caméras oui vous le
voyez tout le monde attend ici la chef
du gouvernement il y a une dizaine de
télévision et tout autant de radios
alors les caméras sont braquées dans
l'axe du couloir entre la cour et
l'hémicycle c'est là que nous devrions
apercevoir Elisabeth borne qui montra
donc ensuite à la tribune de l'Assemblée
nationale pour déclencher le 49-3 alors
la tenter longue vous le voyez les
députés continuent pour l'instant le
texte mais elle pourrait arriver d'une
minute à l'autre merci Stéphanie
Despierre Charles
a acquis la faute sur l'utilisation du
49-3 mais on n'est pas là pour dire
c'est la faute d'un tel ou d'une telle
on est tous des parlementaires on est là
pour faire de la politique moi ce que je
n'arrive pas à comprendre dans le débat
budgétaire et je rebondis sur ce que
vient dire mon collègue dit Philippot
c'est que cet été on a eu un texte
budgétaire le paquet pouvoir d'achat
avec un projet de loi de finance
rectification avec des gros guillemets
rectificatif cet été on a pu faire voter
ce texte
puisque avant le début de l'examen du
texte peut-être à l'exception de la
France insoumise quasiment tous les
groupes de position avaient dit nous
sommes prêts à travailler sur ce texte
et d'ailleurs une bonne partie des
oppositions ont voté là moi ce que
j'arrive pas à comprendre dans vos
raisonnements mes cheveux dit Philippot
c'est que avant le début de l'examen du
texte votre groupe a dit nous ne
voterons pas le budget quoi qu'il arrive
donc de nous dire que c'est notre
responsabilité
d'utiliser le 49-3 j'ai du mal à le
comprendre parce que avant l'examen du
texte si vous aviez dit on peut discuter
on peut trouver un moyen de faire passer
ce texte en prenant en compte notamment
vos avis ce qu'on a pu faire cet été
peut-être que on aurait pu empêcher
l'utilisation du 49-3 donc moi je trouve
qu'il y a une véritable tradition il y a
une contradiction aujourd'hui dans la
position des républicains vous pouvez
pas d'un côté nous dire avant l'examen
du texte on ne votera pas ce budget quoi
qu'il arrive et ensuite nous reprocher
de ne pas prendre en compte ce que vous
avez ce que vous avez proposé pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a pas pu faire cet automne
ce que nous avons fait cet été voilà
répondez
sur deux sujets bien éloignés mais
chacun voit midi à sa porte qu'avons
nous dit quand le budget a été présenté
et le budget c'est quand même une
stratégie politique qui engage la France
à long terme nous avons dit il y a
quatre lignes rouges qui pour nous sont
infranchissables dans le budget tel
qu'il est présenté le niveau de la dette
qui devient insoutenable et sur lequel
il n'y a pas d'effort ensuite la
stratégie énergétique ensuite le sort
qui est réservé à nos collectivités et
enfin la revalorisation du travail
quatre principaux quatre principaux
toucher très vite on s'est rendu compte
que c'était fermé et nous ce qu'on a dit
c'est avec ces lignes aussi bien au
Sénat qu'à l'Assemblée avec ces lignes
rouges affranchissables tel qu'elles
sont présentées dans ce budget là
l'absence d'effort sur ces sujets là et
bien nous ne pourrons pas accompagner ce
texte ce texte là et je suis désolé on a
été élu en tant que député d'opposition
c'est pour changer la trajectoire
erratique qui est celle d'Emmanuel
Macron depuis 5 ans et qui on peut
reprendre tous les conseils moi j'étais
celui de ses députés qui étaient déjà là
le mandat dernier j'ai vu Nicolas Hulot
et bien rigolait quand on lui disait que
la programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie était une vaste blague et
qu'elle nous conduisait dans le mur ils
ont insisté pour fermer les centrales
nucléaires regardez où nous en sommes
aujourd'hui je pourrais refaire ça sur
chacun des sujets avec le recul qui est
le mien aujourd'hui et en toute
responsabilité on dénonce et on
acceptera pas que certaines lignes
rouges soient franchies donc c'est la
raison de notre opposition aujourd'hui
sur ce sur ce budget je regrette et
après on a tous continué de jouer notre
rôle et tant que ce 49-3 n'arrive pas à
regarder son corps dans l'hémicycle de
débattre et bien on essaye de porter nos
propositions jusqu'à la dernière seconde
et de faire et vous vous auriez été
d'accord pour débattre encore et encore
aller au bout finalement de ce projet de
loi de budget vous auriez pu changer
d'avis mais vous auriez pu changer
d'avis changer de vote
nos propositions et la cohérence globale
d'ensemble qui est celle des
républicains d'un coup s'il s'était
réveillé en disant ils ont raison on le
reconnaît et
vous ne pouvez pas réunir de majorité
non mais très bien mais moi je vous dis
les valeurs je vous dis les valeurs que
je porte et les décisions que je porte
pour la France et je fais pas la Vierge
effaroucher je fais pas semblant d'être
traumatisé par un 49-3 va en avoir huit
ou neuf dans les semaines qui viennent
parce qu'il n'y a pas de majorité mais
maintenant permettez quand même parce
qu'on accepte le débat et d'aller au
fond de chaque sujet alors qu'on sait
bien que ce 49-3 va être déclenché
comporte nos propositions pour l'avenir
et vous savez on a eu raison sur le
nucléaire aujourd'hui malheureusement
dans des circonstances tragiques Olivier
Véran reconnait parce que moi j'étais là
aussi en 2018 le débat il l'immigration
avec Gérard Collomb quand on disait
expulsion des délinquants étrangers qui
n'ont rien à faire sur le territoire et
pas recevoir l'hospitalité de la France
maintenant et bien monsieur Véran à
l'époque qui nous critiquait fortement
pour ces positions là nous dit le
gouvernement a peut-être manqué
d'efficacité sur ces sujets là et bien
et bien alors
allons-y très bien soyons efficaces
soyons pragmatiques mais il est temps de
reconnaître que sur beaucoup de sujets
on a eu raison et c'est ça que je
revendique aujourd'hui vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec ce que dit Fabien dit
Philippot vous n'avez pas la même
trajectoire budgétaire les mêmes options
finalement il y a pas de majorité
alternative dans cette hémicycle pour
voter ce budget ah non ça c'est clair
qu'il y a pas de majorité alternative ça
on est parfaitement d'accord et
d'ailleurs ce que vous dites c'est bien
parce que ça met le point ça met le
doigt sur un point précis qui a été
relevé à plusieurs reprises par la
majorité pour essayer de discréditer les
oppositions c'est que effectivement les
républicains votre contre le budget nous
votons contre la nups votre compte le
budget
et des fois on va tous ensemble des
amendements et quasiment à chaque fois
on nous a parlé de collusion des
oppositions qui n'ont rien à voir qui
sont pas cohérentes mais désolé mais
nous c'est pas la macronie je pense que
la news même si on partage pas les mêmes
valeurs c'est pas la macronie les
républicains non plus et nous notre seul
intérêt c'est celui des Français alors
si des fois sur un sujet on arrive à se
retrouver pour l'intérêt des Français
exemple
d'un élément mais qui paraît tellement
normal bah il y a les vitacs il y a moi
ce qui me touche plus particulièrement
la demi-part fiscale pour les veufs et
les veuves notamment d'anciens
combattants c'est des éléments ou on
devrait tous se retrouver il devrait pas
y avoir de 90 et les oppositions c'est
caca
combattants a été voté elle a été votée
est-ce que ce sera conservé parce que
nous avons notre position en cours de
débat mais heureusement ce qui montre
contrairement à ce que vous dites nous
sommes capables des constructifs fiers
on était aussi ont été adoptés où vous
avez été contre et vous nous avez dit
qu'on n'était pas cohérent notre
cohérence à tous c'est l'intérêt nous
avons voté un amendement à l'unanimité
qui concerne les agriculteurs voilà oui
avant vous avez dit qu'on a accepté
qu'on a voté aucun des amendements et
qu'on rejette tout en bloc c'est faux
hier nous avons voté tard dans la nuit
des amendements
il y a des amendements qui ont été votés
effectivement par toutes les oppositions
mais c'était quoi des majorités de
circonstances
ou sur une autre qui est des accords qui
franchissent l'ensemble des groupes
enfin quand on prend un outil comme
l'exit tax il s'agit donc d'un mécanisme
de lutte contre l'évasion fiscale il
s'agit de faire rentrer de l'argent qui
vient du fait que certaines personnes
émigurent fiscalement pour échapper à
l'impôt tout le monde est d'accord avec
ça normalement je veux dire si on pose
la question en français est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord pour lutter contre
l'évasion fiscale normalement la réponse
comme on dit la question est vite
répondue donc il peut arriver que sur
certains sujets il y a des accords qui
se passe qui sont d'ailleurs sur le sur
la taxation des super dividendes je le
répète mais ça venait de la majorité ça
venait du groupe modem il y a des
députés à l'intérieur de du groupe
Renaissance c'est-à-dire
voté cet amendement modèle qui ont voté
cet amendement là donc ça n'est il
arrive parfois que le rassemblement
national vote avec la macronie il arrive
parfois que nous nous votions avec la
macronie ça dépend des sujets il y a des
il y a des lignes de clivage qui sont
pas les mêmes que ce qu'on avait d'abord
mais ce qui se passe en fait c'est que
les macronistes n'ont pas enregistré
l'information principale issue du mois
de juin il n'y a plus de majorité
absolue à l'Assemblée nationale il va
falloir que a priori non il va falloir
que ça rentre dans les têtes et que sur
ce qui concerne un projet de loi de
finance c'est précisément ce qui définit
une opposition une majorité normalement
le projet de loi de finances c'est ce
qu'on va faire pour l'année à venir
c'est les objectifs politiques de
l'année à venir donc quand il y a votre
budget il a une cohérence c'est moi de
mon point de vue à moi vous serez pas
d'accord avec ça mais c'est un budget
qui favorise les plus riches et qui ne
l'aimait pas assez à contribution bon et
nous nous proposons une logique qui est
totalement inversée on ne peut donc pas
voter ce projet de loi de finance
puisque nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec
ces objectifs politiques c'est logique
oui mais vous dites si il y a des
amendements qui sont votés ensemble dans
ce moment-là ça voudrait le coup pour
aller au bout et peut-être de le voter
une fille de le changer d'avis il y en
avait beaucoup qui avait été adopté mais
par exemple le fait qu'il n'y ait pas le
rétablissement de l'ISF pour nous et ben
c'est une ligne rouge pour nous il faut
il faut qu'il y ait l'ISF dedans mais je
vais plus loin le 49-3 c'est un outil
qui ne peut être utilisé que sur le
projet de loi de finance le projet de
loi de finance de la sécurité sociale et
un autre texte lors d'une session et
bien il va arriver à un moment donné où
le gouvernement va devoir proposer
d'autres textes que le projet de loi de
finance et que le projet de loi de
finance de la sécurité sociale donc le
problème d'un gouvernement qui est
minoritaire qui a perdu les élections
législatives se représentera dans
quelques mois et si le gouvernement
utilise son joker 49-3 sur la réforme
des retraites pour faire passer la
retraite à 65 ans il aura fait la
démonstration qu'il est un gouvernement
qui gouverne contre le peuple c'est à
dire contre la volonté populaire
personne n'est d'accord avec le
rétablissement de la retraite à 65 ans
si vous interrogez les Français
largement donc on a un gouvernement qui
donne un peu l'impression d'être une
citadelle assiégée qui se débat avec ce
qu'il a mais qui continue avec les mêmes
méthodes que celle qu'il avait lorsqu'il
avait une majorité absolue voilà la
situation politique dans laquelle je
vais répondre
mais dans majorité relative il y a le
mot majorité et il reste un fait
majoritaire et il faut qu'il y ait un
fait majoritaire la Cinquième République
se construit autour du fait majoritaire
c'est pour ça que le Président de la
République élu au suffrage universel qui
obtient la majorité du suffrage des
français même si vous êtes contre lui
c'est lui qui a gagné et nous formons à
trois groupes la majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale je pense qu'il faut aussi
dédramatiser l'utilisation du 49-3 il a
utilisé il était utilisé 89 fois
depuis 1959 depuis que la Cinquième
République existe et figurez-vous qu'il
a été utilisé la première fois sous la
Cinquième République à l'hiver 1959 pour
un projet de loi de finance ordinaire
est-ce que on considère que le général
de Gaulle a gouverné contre le peuple je
ne pense pas et ce qu'on considère que
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing au vin des
contre le peuple je ne pense pas est-ce
que Mitterrand a gouverné contre le
peuple je ne pense pas Chirac a-t-il
gouverné contre le peuple je ne pense
pas donc il faut sortir aussi de ce
débat qui je pense m'ont est très
intéressant constitutionnel politique
très théorique sur le 49.3 mais c'est un
outil qui est à la disposition du
gouvernement pour faire tourner les
institutions
ne peut pas utiliser autant de fois
qu'on veut avant on le pouvait avant la
révision de 2008
sarkozytes budgétaires et un texte en
plus ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
dans les mois qui viennent il y aura un
blocage à l'Assemblée nationale il y
aura un blocage du pays on ne pourra
plus légiférer c'est plutôt aux autres
groupes aux autres groupes de poser
cette question
précédente je pense qu'on doit faire la
part des choses de rôle important du
député le premier par son positionnement
dans la majorité ou dans l'opposition et
son appartenance un groupe il porte une
cohérence d'ensemble et donc et bien sa
position sur un texte aussi important
aussi large qui brasse tous les sujets
qu'un budget elle se fait par rapport à
cette cohérence globale c'est la
première chose la deuxième même si on
sait un moment donné qu'on est pas
majoritaire qu'on ne va pas gagner tous
les votes qu'au final parce que ralent
49-3 le budget sera adopté et bien on
doit se battre sur chaque amendement
pour à la marge essayer d'obtenir les
choses qu'on pense les bonnes par
rapport à notre valeur pour les acteurs
économiques pour nos territoires pour
les gens qui pour les gens qui
travaillent et ça quelle que soit le
texte à l'issue qui va être adopté et
bien on doit se battre sur chaque
amendement pour y parvenir donc ça c'est
la logique globalement de nos débats
ensuite maintenant si on met en
perspective la période qui vient
effectivement toute la période
budgétaire va se jouer par 49-3 c'est
inévitable on le sait déjà ensuite cet
été il n'y a pas eu de 49-3 ce qu'on
escompte tout ça notre niveau c'est que
justement le groupe LR a joué un rôle
particulier c'est-à-dire que vous avez
voté vous avez portez vos voix la
majorité en modifiant un certain nombre
d'amendements de d'articles sur les
textes mais vous avez apporté vos voix
ce qui a permis et bien de faire de
faire voter des détails d'urgence dans
une crise aussi profonde qu'on l'a connu
c'était c'était effectivement une chose
maintenant donc c'est terminé la
bienveillance
des réponses qui me concerne vous savez
the
à titre personnel en tout cas j'ai
toujours je pense été parmi les plus
exigeants y compris au sein des
républicains maintenant ça veut dire une
chose les textes qui vont venir dans les
mois qui viennent et bien qu'il traite
des aspects liés à l'économie à la
sécurité à l'immigration s'ils veulent
avoir une chance de passer il faudra
qu'il soit un temps soit peu conforme à
nos valeurs et qu'il tienne compte des
grands principes que j'ai énoncé tout à
l'heure et qui ont été bafoués pendant 5
ans c'est ça que ça veut dire parce
qu'il y aura un 49-3 utilisé pendant la
session ok alors le gouvernement devrait
un peu bien choisir sur quel texte parce
que pour les autres il devra se
débrouiller soit pour avoir sur sa
gauche une partie de la nuque qui
l'accompagne soit sur sa droite une
partie une partie de républicain ou du
rassemblement national d'ailleurs qui
accepteront de valider ces textes-là
mais on sera très très exigeant sur le
sur le contenu et il faudra vraiment
maintenant et bien on se rend compte la
situation de notre pays elle est assez
dramatique le déclassement continue de
ce produire
l'insécurité malheureusement progresse
encore les dérives migratoires sont là
donc notre responsabilité à nous ça sera
de faire en sorte qu'on ait pu comme on
a eu pendant cinq ans des textes de
communication politique qui brassent
tout mais qui ne règle rien et que
l'écart entre les discours et la réalité
petit à petit se rapproche donc on sera
extrêmement exigeant ça veut dire que là
on a pas recherché pour vous les
oppositions le compromis dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
Kevin mauvieux pas du tout alors pas du
tout parce que on en parlait tout à
l'heure le nombre d'amendements votés
par la majorité relative avec les
oppositions si on devait faire un taux
je pense qu'on est à 2% 3% d'une
centaine d'amendements pourraient être
votés pourraient être conservés dans ce
texte final on va voir le compromis et
ce que disait mon collègue sur le 49-3
qui est au final un débat intéressant
mais qui est un peu superficiel parce
qu'il a déjà été utilisé plein de fois
là où ce débat là est intéressant c'est
qu'il va être très révélateur de
l'écoute du gouvernement et d'Emmanuel
Macron des Français et un message des
Français qui fasse le 49-3 parce
qu'aucune des oppositions de voter le
budget c'est enfin on va pas faire on va
pas faire l'autruche c'est normal voilà
c'est comme c'est pas le premier qui non
c'est pas le premier effet normal par
contre qu'il est laissé toute une
semaine de débat complet vous avez dit
503 ou 57 heures je les ai pas compté
mais de débat sur SPLM avec des
oppositions que les Français ont choisi
et qui se sont qui sont tombés d'accord
sur des amendements importants pour les
français si derrière le gouvernement
joue à la pêche aux canards avec ça en
tendance à baguette et en sortant trois
amendements pour dire on a repris des
amendements là par contre ce 49-3 va
devenir très problématique parce qu'il
sera la démonstration par les faits
qu'Emmanuel Macron et la Renaissance
méprise le peuple et le choix du peuple
Antoine je crois que finalement ce débat
sur le 49-3 permet de revenir à des
questions fondamentales en matière de
démocratie parlementaire en fait le
fonctionnement de la Cinquième
République avec
une inversion du calendrier législatif
et le fait que les élections
législatives soient juste après
l'élection présidentielle ont pendant
des années fait que en réalité on
n'avait pas de séparation entre le
pouvoir exécutif et le pouvoir
législatif aujourd'hui on se retrouve
dans une situation dans laquelle les
Françaises et les Français et nous-mêmes
d'ailleurs acteurs politiques nous
sommes en train de redécouvrir ce que
c'est qu'une démocratie parlementaire
une démocratie parlementaire normalement
c'est un endroit dans lequel on essaye
d'obtenir des majorités sur des textes
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure parfois à
gauche parfois à droite on essaie de
créer des coalitions qui sont des
coalitions cohérentes sur sur des idées
et c'est en quelque sorte ce que vous ne
faites pas pour l'instant il y a dans un
très large dans ce que nous sommes avec
Eric Coquerel en direct de la salle des
quatre colonnes le débat sur les
recettes au profit de l'Union européenne
vient de se terminer la séance est
suspendue pour 10 minutes
européen il est Parlement nationaux et
pour ma part je regrette que cette
contagion anti-démocratique gagne
aujourd'hui le parlement national que
nous avons puisque nous n'allons pas
pouvoir voter le budget de la France qui
est quand même une des prérogatives les
plus importantes de l'Assemblée
nationale et des députés qui est siègent
donc c'est un coup de force
démocratique auquel on va assister et en
plus il s'est doublé depuis des jours
j'allais dire d'un mépris de l'Assemblée
nationale puisqu'on a en réalité le
gouvernement a fait en sorte que on
l'enterrement sur le débat on a
simplement examiné 840 amendements j'ai
jamais vu le gouvernement et une
majorité ne pas chercher à accélérer les
débats quand il veut essayer d'atteindre
j'allais dire le vote d'une loi avant la
fin des débats prévus et restait
aujourd'hui les débats les plus
importants sur le CVAE c'est-à-dire les
impôts de production ou le gouvernement
pouvait être battus sur la taxation sur
les super profits sur les collectivités
et donc il interrompt j'allais dire pour
cesser l'hémorragie des défaites qu'il
calculer parce que tout simplement ce
49-3 c'est l'aveu d'échec d'un
gouvernement qui est minoritaire dans
l'assemblée et qui donc passe en force
voilà je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas
un jour anodin apparemment on s'attend à
d'autres 49-3 avec le PLFSS ou le PLF
dans sa partie 2 et je crois que pour
notre démocratie notre République c'est
un vrai problème qui est posé
aujourd'hui voilà ce que je voulais dire
voilà c'était ricoquerel député la
France insoumise mais surtout rapporteur
général du budget Charles zinstenstool
je voudrais vous faire réagir on parle
de comédie c'est ce qu'a dit au début de
son propos
Eric Coquerel les amendements n'ont pas
tous été examinés vous n'avez pas été au
bout du du budget et surtout vous vous
arrêtez avant l'article 5 qui est sur la
CVE sont des impôts de production que
vous souhaitez supprimer oui c'est
dommage moi j'aurais bien aimé
d'ailleurs qu'on discute la c.v.e mais
bon écoutez moi je suis pas là pour
donner les bons et les mauvais points à
Eric Coquerel est un député les filles
il est dans une opposition
frontale avec notre majorité alors je
vais vous redonner la parole d'un tout
petit instant Fabien Roussel est en
direct avec nous de la salle des quatre
colonnes qui va s'abattre sur tous les
débats que nous avons menés depuis
plusieurs jours
maintenant le dernier espoir qui nous
reste c'est que les amendements qui ont
été adoptés majoritairement au sein de
cette hémicycle soit retenu au moins
dans le projet de loi de finance que le
gouvernement s'apprête à conserver en
mettant fin au débat c'est vraiment un
coup dur pour la démocratie et les mêmes
qui nous donnent des leçons sur le
respect des accords majoritaires dans
les entreprises sont les mêmes qui ici
vont s'asseoir sur les votes
majoritaires qui se sont exprimés
pendant ce PLF c'est vraiment un déni de
démocratie un coup de force et c'est
très dur pour l'ensemble des
parlementaires
merci
démocratie coup de force absence de
dialogue voilà ce que disait Fabien
Roussel pour le parti communiste
Stéphanie Despierre vous êtes salle des
quatre colonnes il y a évidemment
beaucoup de journalistes on s'attend à
l'arrivée d'Elizabeth borne d'une minute
à l'autre elle aurait déjà quitté
Matignon oui on s'attend 10 minutes à
l'autre à l'arrivée à d'Elizabeth borne
elle est elle a été aperçue à pied dans
les environs de l'Assemblée elle devrait
donc monter rentrer dans l'hémicycle
d'ici à quelques minutes pour s'exprimer
à la tribune et annoncer le 49-3 cela
interromperait immédiatement toute
discussion sur le projet de loi de
finance 2023 et les débats reprendraient
ensuite dans plusieurs jours sur la
deuxième partie de ce budget merci
Stéphanie des pierres joues laisser
répondre Charles c'est vrai qu'on entend
là les oppositions qui sont déjà dans
l'après 49-3 alors que effectivement
cette arme constitutionnelle n'a pas été
encore utilisé et qu'on attend la
première ministre d'une minute à l'autre
on entend des démocratie
de force vous avez quand même dit que
vous souhaitiez dialoguer que vous
souhaitiez concerter après votre
majorité relative sont excessifs je
pense qu'il faut mesurer les propos et
démocraties ce sont des textes et
surtout c'est une constitution et la
Constitution que ce sont choisis les
Français par référendum il y a plus de
60 ans c'est la Constitution de la
Cinquième République qui prévoit un
article 49 alinéa 3 que le gouvernement
peut utiliser il va probablement être
utilisé dans quelques minutes pour la
90e fois voilà alors est-ce que tous les
présidents de la République précédent
qui l'ont utilisé n'était pas
démocratique je ne le je ne le pense pas
et la démocratie c'est aussi de décider
parce que notre pays a déjà souffert
dans son histoire sous la quatrième et
la Troisième République
d'assembler qui n'arrivait pas à dégager
de décision pour pour les Français et la
France doit avoir un budget nous avons
eu un débat de plusieurs jours et moi je
regrette encore une fois que avant que
ce débat ait commencé toutes les
oppositions et de toute façon nous ne
chercherons pas à vous aider d'une façon
ou d'une autre à le faire adopter il y a
aussi les dialogues de Bercy qui ont été
lancés à quoi ont servi ces dialogues de
Bercy moi je me pose vraiment la
question le gouvernement attendu la main
Bruno Le Maire et Gabriel Attal ont
tendu la main à toutes les oppositions
pour les associer à la construction du
budget et quelques jours après ils ont
dit on votera pas le budget donc voilà
pour moi tout ça c'est un dialogue un
peu hypocrite quoi pourtant vous aviez
promis des débats et les débats vont
s'arrêter alors que nous n'en sommes
qu'après l'argent
qu'une partie du groupe liberté et
territoire ou qu'une partie du groupe
partie socialiste vote le budget avec
nous moi je vous le dis j'aurais été
très heureux le problème c'est qu'ils
ont tous dit nous par contre on ne
votera pas avec vous alors vous voyez
sur ces images ce qu'on appelle le
périmètre sacré de l'autre côté de la
salle des quatre colonnes il y a
effectivement beaucoup de collaborateurs
qui sont là la première ministre
Elisabeth borne serait en train
d'arriver on sait déjà qu'elle a quitté
Matignon et le regard évidemment tout ce
par la fenêtre on aperçoit aussi des dép
donc de la première ministre et vous
avez entendu comme moi la sonnerie la
première ministre vient de traverser et
bien un salon de l'hémistique de
l'Assemblée nationale cette sonnerie
indique donc tous les députés et tout
ceux qui peuvent rejoindre l'hémistique
doivent le faire désormais car il va et
y avoir une déclaration dans l'hémicycle
de l'Assemblée nationale la première
ministre Elisabeth borne va donc très
certainement monter à la tribune pour
dire qu'elle utilise le 49-3 c'est un
constitutionnel l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la Constitution qui mettrait donc fin au
débat sur le projet de loi de finances
et dans ces cas là le texte budgétaire
serait donc considéré comme adopté avant
même le vote c'est à dire qu'il n'y
aurait pas de vote le texte serait
adopté Charles Simpson est-ce que vous
avez des informations comme quoi la
première ministre est arrivée est-ce que
sur les boucles télégrammes par contre
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien aller je
pense comme tous mes collègues parce
qu'on est trois à vie notre premier
mandat on aimerait bien je pense aller
dans les
secondes qui viennent
avant de partir
si vous voulez allez-y Antoine les Oman
une dernière intervention un débat
vraiment très intéressant et vous avez
dit collègue tout à l'heure quelque
chose qui m'a qui m'a interpellé il a
dit
cette Constitution de la Cinquième
République a été adoptée par référendum
il y a maintenant 60 ans et moi j'aime
bien revenir au texte qui du moment
fondateur de notre République quand nous
avons fondé la République en 1793 nous y
avons adjoint une déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen augmenter et
voici ce qu'elle disait à son article 28
un peuple a toujours le droit de revoir
de réformer et de changer sa
constitution une génération ne peut
assujettir assez lois les générations
futures et bien aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il est temps que notre génération la
nouvelle génération face
cet objet c'est à dire révise la
Constitution face une nouvelle alors
vous vous plaidez pour une sixième
république pour vous supprimeriez
l'article 49 sur la situation est en
train de nous donner raison nous nous
proposons par exemple qui est de la
proportionnelle à l'intérieur de cette
nouvelle Constitution que ça soit
justement une démocratie parlementaire
et que les pouvoirs ne soient pas
concentrés sur les institutions qui a
été annoncé par le président de la
République vous défendrez effectivement
vos propositions c'est une question de
méthode nous nous proposons une
assemblée constituante pour que le
peuple dans son ensemble sans enfin je
veux dire dans l'ensemble des
représentations politiques et même
également partir à au sort puisse donner
son avis sur une nouvelle constitution
et que cette Constitution soit soumise à
un référendum voilà une manière
trois Fabien di Philippot c'est une arme
constitutionnelle elle a été utilisée
par la droite quant à la droite était au
pouvoir et je vous remercie Antoine Léon
vous pouvez filer elle a été utilisée
par énormément de gouvernement en
premier chef Michel Rocard et là et la
gauche mais ce n'est pas le débat mais
vous savez ce qui doit nous inquiéter
c'est que ce 49-3 ne résout rien
monsieur zinson studiait on aurait dû
les accompagner il y aurait pas eu de
49,3 c'est quand même une conception
bizarre du débat ça serait facile si ça
se passait comme ça les hypothèses sur
lequel il est basé sont fausses aucune
agence aucun expert n'annonce plus d'un
pour cent de croissance pour la France
l'année prochaine ça veut dire qu'il y
aura un impact sur les recettes et que
le budget d'ores et déjà caduque il a il
prévoit aussi une inflation limitée à
4,3% au rythme où vont les choses avec
déjà plus 15% au 1er janvier annoncé par
le gouvernement sur les factures
d'énergie de nos concitoyens on peut
penser que ça paraît légèrement très
optimiste donc nous on continuera le
combat parce que cette incestérité
budgétaire elle se traduit par de la
dette et aujourd'hui quand on va
emprunter à des taux qui seront proches
de 3% et bien les gens vont comprendre
que la dette a un impact de l'État a un
impact direct sur leur quotidien et ce
qu'on veut éviter c'est que comme on l'a
connu
l'hémicycle vient d'ouvrir et il y a
LeBron Pivet est au perchoir la première
ministre est également là je vous
remercie Kevin mauvieux d'être venu sur
ce plateau merci Fabien a dit Filippo la
parole
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général du budget
mesdames et messieurs les députés
il y a quelques mois devant vous lors de
ma déclaration de politique générale
j'ai appelé tous les groupes de l'arc
républicains à bâtir ensemble au service
de notre pays et de nos concitoyens
dès cet été nous sommes parvenus à nous
mettre d'accord sur des textes pour
protéger le pouvoir d'achat des Français
il y a quelques jours vous avez voté le
projet de loi relatif au marché du
travail
hier le projet de loi d'orientation et
de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur a été adopté à une très
large majorité au Sénat
en abordant le débat budgétaire nous
connaissions les difficultés face à nous
un budget traduit une ambition et des
engagements
ceux sur lesquels le président de la
République est la majorité se sont
présentés devant les Français
nous aurions pu alors renoncer à la
recherche d'un compromis mais nous avons
fait le choix du dialogue
car si nous ne convergeons pas sur tout
nous pouvons nous rejoindre quand
l'intérêt général est en cause
dès cet été le ministre de l'économie et
des finances et celui des comptes
publics ont lancé les dialogues de Bercy
j'ai personnellement reçu tous les
présidents des groupes parlementaires
et ces derniers jours encore en
commission et en séance publique le
débat s'est tenu et nous avons examiné
loyalement toutes les propositions
toutes les idées
mais aujourd'hui deux constats
s'imposent
d'abord au moment où nous parlons au
sixième jour de débat bon nombre
d'amendements sont encore à examiner
et tout indique que nous ne tiendrons
pas les délais prévus pour la discussion
de cette première partie du PLF
[Applaudissements]
ensuite
ensuite et surtout les oppositions pour
toute réaffirmer leur volonté de rejeter
le texte
en responsabilité nous devons donner un
budget à notre pays
les Français attendent de nous de la
cohérence de l'action et des résultats
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aussi
aussi sur le fondement de l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement pour la première partie du
projet de loi de finance pour 2023
le
texte le texte vous plaît je présente
aujourd'hui
s'il vous plaît seul madame la Première
ministre à la parole le texte que je
présente aujourd'hui n'est pas le
décalque du projet qui vous a été
initialement soumis il a été nourri
complété amendée corrigé même suite au
débat de ces derniers jours en
commission et dans l'émission
une centaine d'amendements a été retenue
y compris des amendements des
oppositions
cette décision c'est le choix de la
responsabilité
car je le redis nous devons donner un
budget à la France un budget cohérent
avec les engagements pris devant les
Français pas de hausse d'impôts pas de
hausse de déficit
mesdames et messieurs les députés
mesdames et messieurs les députés ça
n'est pas la fin du débat sur le projet
de loi de finance pour 2023 ce débat
continuera au Sénat comme à l'Assemblée
nationale et à chaque étape nous
garderons intact notre volonté de
dialogue notre devoir d'action et notre
esprit de responsabilité je vous
remercie merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
l'Assemblée nationale prend acte de
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement conformément au
dispositions de l'article 49 à Linéa 3
de la Constitution le texte sur lequel
la première ministre engage la
responsabilité du gouvernement sera
insérée en annexe au compte-rendu de la
présente séance en application de
l'article 155 alinéa premier du
règlement le débat sur ce texte est
immédiatement suspendu ce texte sera
considéré comme adopté sauf si une
motion de censure déposée avant demain
17h45 et voter dans les conditions
prévues à l'article 49 de la
Constitution dans l'hypothèse ou une
motion de censure serait déposée la
Conférence des Présidents fixera la date
et les modalités de sa discussion la
séance est levée
[Applaudissements]
voilà vous êtes en direct sur LCP où
vous venez de suivre l'annonce de la
première ministre qui a donc décidé
d'engager la responsabilité de son
gouvernement sur la première partie du
projet de loi de finances on va tout de
suite écouter Mathilde panot la
présidente
qui se tient devant vous a décidé en se
tenantes de déposer une motion de
censure je voudrais ajouter que si ce
n'est pas une surprise puisque au fond
les premiers à avoir parlé de cette
hypothèse sont les ministres eux-mêmes
c'est évidemment une déception sur le
plan du débat parlementaire et du
fonctionnement de notre démocratie nous
sommes un parlement une Assemblée
nationale plus réaliste que jamais et il
se peut qu'à la faveur du débat
parlementaire le projet de budget de
l'Assemblée ne soit pas celui du
gouvernement mais c'est le Parlement
souverain qui a délibéré et nous en
avons pendant plusieurs jours fait le
démonstration d'adoptant des amendements
qui venaient d'ailleurs de tous les
bancs y compris de ceux de la majorité
aujourd'hui avec ce 49-3 ça n'est pas
les oppositions qui refusent de voter le
budget du gouvernement c'est le
gouvernement qui refuse de voter le
budget de l'Assemblée nationale il
faudra que le Président de la République
le gouvernement se résolve a changé de
méthode et à considérer sérieusement et
véritablement qu'aujourd'hui il y a un
parlementarisme de fait et que les
Français réclament de la vitalité
démocratique nous avons examiné 4
articles sur 25 nous avions pour ceux
qui nous concerne poser un nombre très
raisonnable d'amendements et je crois
que les débats se sont tenus dans la
sérénité ont été le plus souvent de
qualité nous ne pouvons que regretter
cette méthode la condamner et en appeler
à l'esprit de démocratie de l'exécutif
sur les questions de la démocratie le
constat que l'on peut faire c'est que
depuis huit jours
ils nous ont traités comme des
paillassons c'est-à-dire que nous avons
discuté nous avons discuté nos
amendements hier au soir hier au soir
encore avant l'interruption de séance
ils nous ont dit que le débat les
continuer jusqu'au bout que les
amendements seraient étudiés et
aujourd'hui ils font tout le contraire
c'est à dire ils accompagnent leur
brutalité d'un mensonge permanent et
nous ne considérons que c'est une honte
pour notre démocratie de se comporter de
cette façon il y a une opposition que
une opposition forte c'est celle qui a
été envoyé par les Français nous
demandons à ce qu'elle se respectait
merci beaucoup
l'utilisation du 49-3 et un aveu de
faiblesse pour un gouvernement qui ne
sait pas travailler avec la pluralité
politique de l'Assemblée c'est un mépris
pour la qualité des débats nous avons eu
depuis plusieurs jours
cela
était des femmes c'est un mépris pour le
travail qui a été fait depuis des jours
par cette assemblée cela était dit nous
avons su trouver des majorités sur des
amendements extrêmement importants la
super taxe des taxes sur les super
dividendes la question du crédit d'impôt
sur les EHPAD aujourd'hui ce travail est
balayé balayé en quelques heures pour
finalement répondre à un simulacre de
démocratie voilà une semaine que pendant
que nous débattions de manière sereine
et dans un esprit de travail et de
contribution les membres du gouvernement
se succédaient sur les plateaux télé
pour nous dire quand serait utilisé le
49.3 peut-être serait-ce vendredi un an
peut-être bien lundi finalement c'est
mercredi ce simula qu'il avait qu'un
seul objectif faire un écran de fumer
médiatique autour de la du contenu de ce
budget ce budget c'est
l'irresponsabilité climatique c'est
l'incapacité de faire les
investissements pour la transition c'est
la capacité de faire des choix
politiques qui nous permettent
aujourd'hui le dérèglement climatique
mais c'est aussi un budget pour les plus
riches c'est le refus de reprendre
l'impôt de solidaire de solidarité sur
la fortune c'est le refus de la taxe sur
les super profits finalement ce qu'ils
font c'est de refuser le choix des
Français et c'est de contribuer
finalement à assécher le débat
démocratique c'est inacceptable
merci
voilà vous venez d'entendre les quatre
présidents de groupe qui composent la
Nupe donc Cyrielle châtelain à l'instant
pour les écologistes André chassen pour
les communistes Boris Vallot pour les
socialistes et Mathilde panneaux pour la
France insoumise Boris Vallaud a appelé
à un changement de méthode
André Chassaigne a dit que l'opposition
était traitée comme des paillassons
Cyrielle châtelain a parlé de de mépris
et de simulacre elles a mon Agava vous
nous avez rejoint bien sûr sur ce
plateau mais c'est surtout Mathilde
panot la présidente du groupe LFI qui
annonce le dépôt d'une motion de censure
oui les députés de la nupette qui sont
partis de l'hémicycle avant même la fin
de la prise de parole de la première
ministre ils ont donc tenu une
conférence de presse commune salle des
quatre colonnes une motion de censure
sera déposée c'est Cyrielle châtelain la
présidente du groupe écologiste à
l'assemblée qui va la défendre ce sera
peut-être ce weekend peut-être plutôt
lundi effectivement ce qui nous disait
ces groupes de l'Alliance de gauche
c'est que leur motion Elle était déjà
prête
c'est elle est en cours de dépôt me
dit-on il faut la déposer il faut les
signatures physiques hein vraiment on
peut pas être à distance il faut
vraiment avoir à poser sa signature et
elle est remise normalement au
secrétariat général de la Présidence de
l'Assemblée nationale d'émotions de
censure il y en aura pas qu'une Brigitte
sur Nora 2 puisque le rassemblement
national va également déposer sa mission
eux par essai un peu moins pressé
c'était une question d'heure pour eux et
puis voilà attendez une minute à l'autre
en tout cas ce qu'on sait c'est que ces
motion elles étaient en fait déjà
rédigées avant même que la première
ministre engage son gouvernement et
utilise le 49-3 on en va entendre Alexis
Corbière qui est député la France
insoumise il est à vos côtés Stéphanie
Despierre il donc dépose une motion
censure il l'a signé j'imagine
vous avez signé la motion de censure
elle est prête à être déposée je crois
qu'elle est déposée même à l'heure en
nous parlons elle était signée depuis
plusieurs jours toutes les composants de
la nuit Pesse est mis d'accord sur la
résolution qu'il accompagne car vous
savez qu'il y a un petit texte qui
accompagne ça
aussi un horizon plus social plus
écologique plus démocratique que nous
avons porté dans le débat et elle dit
clairement que le 49-3 est un acte de
brutalisation du Parlement que nous ne
serions tolérées pourquoi les posons
cette notion de censure elle est assez
factuelle même si elle a des petits
aspects
identitaires si on comprendrait ce que
je veux dire par là c'est à dire que
elle est elle brosse aussi les raisons
qui qui nous rassemblent donc voilà
c'est on veut pas banaliser ce qui a
lieu j'espère que les Français peut-être
voient ça de loin comprennent que c'est
grave que le Parlement soit piétiné
ainsi merci beaucoup
les républicains en direct que celui de
ce 49-3 c'est une arme que lui propose
la Constitution maintenant si le
gouvernement n'a pas de c'est pas le
fruit du hasard c'est pas le fruit d'une
erreur des Français qui aurait mal voté
mais d'une volonté des Français
d'obliger la majorité de Biger le
gouvernement à écouter l'ensemble des
formations politiques qui les
représentent et donc évidemment
nous nous demandons au gouvernement
c'est le premier 49-3 mais il y en aura
d'autres durant le temps que durera ce
quinquennat il y en aura sans doute 5 6
d'ici la fin de d'ici la fin de de la
session d'ici Noël et donc mon
gouvernement évidemment de retenir un
maximum des propositions qui ont été
faites par les différents groupes
d'opposition
est-ce que vous comptez éventuellement
signer une motion de censure parce qu'il
va y avoir aussi une censure
je crois que la France a suffisamment de
difficultés de désordre des Français
suffisamment de préoccupations le prix
de l'électricité aujourd'hui menace un
très grand nombre de nos entreprises et
d'une véritablement la vie la vie la
survie de ces entreprises
pensons totalement
inutile de rajouter du chaos au chaos
ça t'assemblée nationale elle fonctionne
depuis huit semaines si mes calculs sont
bons depuis la session extraordinaire et
donc très sincèrement ce ne serait pas
sérieux de rajouter du désordre au
désordre laissons cet assemblée
travailler et que le gouvernement écoute
malgré tout malgré cette procédure ce
que les groupes d'opposition lui ont
exprimé tout au long des débats merci
alors que vous ne voulez pas c'était
donc Olivier Marleix le président du
groupe les républicains la première
ministre vient donc d'engager la
responsabilité de son gouvernement et
d'utiliser le 49-3 sur la première
partie du projet de loi de finance un
texte qui est donc considéré comme
adopter sans vote à moins qu'une motion
de censure soit adoptée elle a été déjà
déposée pour la nup et une seconde
motion pour le rassemblement national
devrait être également déposés les
oppositions ont 24 heures pour déposer
leurs motion de censure on comprend en
tout cas qu'à droite il n'y aura pas
d'émotion de censure et que la droite
n'a pas non plus l'intention de voter
une motion qu'elle soit de la nuque ou
encore du rassemblement national on va
écouter maintenant pour la majorité Juan
Balanant il est député MoDem du
Finistère il est avec Stéphanie
Despierres salle des quatre colonnes
la première ministre a enclenché ce
fameux 49-3 l'opposition proteste en
disant que c'est un déni de démocratie
on peut pas dire ça il y a des 49-3 qui
parfois sont des passages en force c'est
une réalité mais celui-là n'est pas un
passage en force on a eu on a eu autant
de débats que un PLF habituel en nombre
d'heures et on a 100 amendement qui sont
retenus je rappelle juste que l'année
dernière le PLF traditionnel 124
amendements alors qu'il y avait
2100 24 amendements retenus aux
définitifs donc franchement on peut pas
dire qu'il y a eu un passage en force
c'est un 49-3 qui est obligé par la
structure la structuration et
l'équilibre politique qui existe dans
cette dans cette hémicycle sur cette
mandature mais n'a rien de scandaleux et
on est très loin d'un passage en force à
mon sens mais même certains de vos
amendements à vous le modem allié de la
majorité allié de renaissance n'ont pas
été retenues oui bah c'est comme ça et
comme la première ministre l'a dit le
match n'est pas fini le débat n'est pas
fini il va y avoir des débats au Sénat
et le texte reviendra ici et nous on a
bon espoir de continuer comme d'habitude
d'ailleurs à essayer de faire avancer un
certain nombre de sujets
de 49-3 bah c'est la même c'est la
logique institutionnelle c'est ce 49-3
qui compte les autres sont des 49-3
techniques qui vont découler tout à fait
logiquement donc il y a rien de il y a
rien de scandaleux là dedans moi je le
redis c'est vraiment un 49-3 particulier
avec un long débat autant qu'un PLF
habituel et surtout beaucoup
d'amendements retenus que ça soit des
amendements de la majorité mais aussi
des amendements de l'opposition merci
beaucoup d'avoir été à nos côtés merci
Stéphanie Despierre alors que Cyrielle
châtelain est en train de s'exprimer
celle des quatre colonnes toutes les
oppositions sont effectivement là on va
l'écouter de délai
donc ça sera vendredi soir samedi ou
lundi on a le temps de voir un peu
voilà mais en tout cas vous annoncez que
le texte nous l'avions dit elle a
annoncé le 49 froid nous l'avons fait
nous avons déposé notre notion de
censure
c'est des premiers signataires nups bien
évidemment
le concours
le contenu du texte mais finalement
c'est les trois piliers qu'on nous a
présenté tout à l'heure la première
c'est un gouvernement sans majorité sans
finalement qui n'a pas demandé la
confiance qui a été mis en difficulté
sur la trajectoire budgétaire financière
c'est un gouvernement qui ne sait pas
faire avec la pluralité de l'Assemblée
nationale et qu'une teint pas compte des
résultats des élections législatives
donc on est un gouvernement qui
aujourd'hui en situation de fébrilité et
de fragilité la deuxième chose c'est
l'irresponsabilité climatique je l'ai
dit il faut regarder au-delà de la forme
le contenu de ce budget pourquoi est-ce
que nous sommes opposés à un certain
nombre de ces mesures pourquoi nous
avons cherché à proposer à l'amender
avec l'ISF climatique c'était un budget
qui ne prend pas en concurrence
climatique aujourd'hui c'est
inacceptable si nous voulons être sur
une trajectoire pour nous protéger
protéger nos enfants les actions c'est
aujourd'hui et la deuxième chose c'est
un budget complètement déconnecté de la
réalité face à l'inflation aujourd'hui
quand les Français travaillent chaque
euro qu'il gagne vaut beaucoup moins on
le voit ça veut dire se restreindre sur
l'alimentation se restreinte sur les
dépenses de carburant ou de chauffage ou
se restreinte sur les loisirs aucun
compte n'est tenu de cette situation de
crise sociale on continue de faire des
cadeaux fiscaux aux grandes entreprises
on refuse d'ouvrir la question du
partage des richesses aujourd'hui on
pourrait faire un autre budget qui
répond à ces deux enjeux de l'urgence
climatique et de l'urgence sociale ce
n'est pas le cas
voilà vous venez d'entendre Cyrielle
châtelain président du groupe écologiste
qui a déposé la motion de censure au nom
de la nuque après l'engagement du 49.3
par la première ministre sur la première
partie du projet de loi de finances 2023
on voit bien que chacun essaye de se
renvoyer la responsabilité de
l'utilisation du 49-3 va écouter à
présent un député de la majorité c'est
le député Renaissance Mathieu Lefebvre
qui est avec vous Stéphanie Despierre il
est députés du Val-de-Marne math Mathieu
Lefebvre vous êtes responsable du texte
pour renaissance de ce dans ce budget
pourquoi il n'était pas possible de
continuer les débats il était pas
possible de continuer les débats parce
que toutes les oppositions se sont
alliées pour nous dire qu'elles allaient
voter contre ce budget et le 49-3 c'est
de leur responsabilité à elle nous en
gouvernement et majorité responsable on
souhaite pouvoir protéger les Français
de l'inflation on souhaite pouvoir payer
les Français au 1er janvier prochain la
France a besoin d'un budget
sauf que c'est un peu la loi de la
majorité relative vous êtes obligé de
faire des compromis vous auriez pu y
parvenir le compromis il suppose des
agents du compromis quand tous les tous
les groupes politiques nous disent avant
même d'avoir lu la première ligne du
texte qui vont voter contre il est
impossible de dresser des compromis
maintenant ça veut pas dire pour autant
qu'on va pas essayer de retenir dans le
texte qui sera soumis au Parlement des
amendements de bon sens qui viennent à
la fois de la droite et la gauche dès
l'instant qui ne dénature pas notre
projet politique ni budgétaire mais
encore une fois on peut pas avoir un
compromis avec des gens qui nous ont dit
dès le départ circuler il y a rien à
voir sauf que certains nombre
d'amendements une dizaine ont été
adoptées ici par les députés contre la
vie du gouvernement est-ce que ces
amendements seront repris et lesquels
il y a des amendements qui ont été
adoptés ici à l'unanimité par exemple
comme la demi-part pour les veuves
d'anciens combattants ces amendements
ils seront repris les amendements qu'on
a adopté hier soir en faveur de nos
agriculteurs adoptés à l'unanimité ils
seront repris des amendements en faveur
de la politique familiale notamment le
relèvement du plafond du crédit d'impôt
pour la garde d'enfants adopter à
l'unanimité ils seront repris en
revanche tous les amendements qui ne
correspondent pas à notre projet
politique qui consiste à revaloriser le
travail et à favoriser une politique de
l'offre pour que les entreprises
puissent investir et créer de l'emploi
et tous les amendements qui dénaturent
notre projet budgétaire en disant qu'il
y ait plus d'impôts ou plus de taxes ça
n'est pas possible on les retiendra pas
donc pas de taxe sur les super profits
pas de taxes sur les super dividendes
sur les super profils au gouvernement a
déposé des amendements qui traduisent
l'accord européen c'est simplement
européen rien de plus simplement mais
tout l'accord européen est rien que
l'accord européen parce que on veut pas
se mettre dans une position dans
laquelle la France taxerait plus que ses
voisins on veut pas se mettre dans une
position dans laquelle la France sera en
difficulté par rapport à ses voisins
l'accord européen c'est essentiel merci
beaucoup d'avoir été merci Stéphanie
DESPER Elsa mon dingue avant on voit
bien que chacun se renvoie un peu la
responsabilité de cet utilisation du
49-3 la première ministre a dit dialogue
de Bercy elle a reçu tous les
parlementaires mais voilà il faut un
budget pour la France oui ce sont des
arguments qu'on entend depuis longtemps
puisque comme vous l'avez dit ça tombe
du 49-3 elle plane sur le budget depuis
des semaines en fait de toute façon
c'était inévitable pourquoi parce que
les oppositions c'est politique on ne
vote pas un budget de la mage enfin du
gouvernement sinon on appartient à la
majorité et quand le gouvernement dit on
est d'accord pour négocier mais c'est
pas de hausse d'impôts pas de dette
supplémentaire en fait ça veut dire
qu'aucune de proposition des oppositions
ne peut être véritablement acceptée donc
on se retrouve aujourd'hui avec la fin
attendue c'est à dire à 49-3 sur le
texte allez on prend une dernière
réaction celle de Jean-Philippe Tanguy
pour le rassemblement national député RN
de la somme qui est avec Stéphanie des
pierres
la première ministre vient de déclencher
le 49-3 est-ce que vous le rassemblement
national vous allez déposer une motion
de censure oui nous allons déposer une
notion censure d'ici demain on a 24
heures pour le faire voilà Marine Le Pen
et le groupe souhaite peser les mots
bien les choisir pour qu'elle soit le
plus consensuelle possible la plus
rassemble possible car nous espérons
toujours que d'autres députés d'autres
forces politiques pourraient la soutenir
même l'assigner quel sera le message de
cette notion de censure le message il
est assez simple c'est d'abord que le
gouvernement de n'a pas pris acte en
fait des résultats des législatives il
croit toujours qu'il est majoritaire qui
peut faire passer ses feuilles de route
malgré le vote des Français il ne fait
pas de vrai dialogue et surtout il ne
fait pas de compromis et donc il
n'arrive même pas à Salier à des forces
politiques qui l'ont soutenu la
présidentielle comme les centristes ou
une grande partie ou même la totalité
d'ailleurs de LR donc le gouvernement
est plus isolé que jamais et l'autre
problème c'est que le budget est quand
même très mauvais je rappelle que c'est
150 milliards de déficit c'est un record
historique de taxes et d'impôts par
rapport au PIB donc c'est un budget de
faillite et enfin qui ne répond pas aux
grandes crises de la France notamment à
la crise sociale je rappelle que dans ce
budget il y a plus de soutien pour le
carburant au 1er janvier 2023 il y a pas
de soutien pour le fuel pas de soutien
pour le bois il y a pas de soutien sur
les produits de première nécessité voilà
c'est aussi un budget qui malgré toutes
ses dépenses ne répond pas à des graves
problèmes pour les Français merci
d'avoir été avec nous pour réagir à se
déclenchement du 49-3 merci Stéphanie
Despierre merci et Elsa mandingavat de
nous avoir accompagnés dans cette
émission spéciale je vous rappelle donc
la première ministre a engagé la
responsabilité de son gouvernement par
l'utilisation du 49-3 sur la première
partie du projet de loi de finances qui
est considéré comme adoptée sans vote
sauf votre d'une motion de censure la
nuque en a déposé une et le
rassemblement national Jean-Philippe
Tanguy vient de nous le confirmer on
déposera une seconde et elles sont
débattues d'ici la fin de semaine ou le
début de la semaine prochaine voilà ce
que l'on pouvait dire toutes les
réactions sur cette utilisation de cette
arme constitutionnelle sachez que
miramankawa reviendra sur tous les
développements et sur cet utilisation
d'un savon regarde à 19 rendez-vous donc
sur LCP merci encore Stéphanie
Despierres en direct de la salle des
quatre colonnes et Merci à VOUS Elsa qui
va rester bien évidemment sur les
chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]